unión europea no financiará la
construcción de muros en sus fronteras
esta fue la declaración de la presidenta
de la comisión europea en la última
jornada de la cumbre en bruselas
dónde hubo un debate sobre la llamada
infraestructura física y tuve muy claro
que existe una posición común desde hace
mucho tiempo en la comisión europea y
con el parlamento europeo de que no
habrá financiación de alambres de púas o
muros
el anuncio llega luego de que 12 países
del bloque comunitario enviarán una
carta en la que pidieron al organismo
más presupuesto para este fin varias
naciones en especial lituania polonia y
letonia acusan a belarús con quien
comparten fronteras de permitir el paso
de inmigrantes provenientes de medio
oriente y áfrica hacia el espacio
europeo en lo que el bloque ha
considerado una represalia por las
sanciones que le impuso al gobierno de
alexandr lukashenko hui con 72 behaviors
de palo buscando en 3 a height
consideramos el comportamiento del
gobierno de belarús como un ataque
híbrido las personas utilizadas por el
presidente lukashenko son víctimas
debemos ayudarlos la vida de nadie
debería ser utilizada para cuestiones
políticas
esto es una instrumentalización de la
migración para ejercer presión política
sobre la unión europea en los últimos
meses la situación creada por los flujos
migratorios desde belarús se ha agravado
planteando un reto a las autoridades
fronterizas entrar a europa desde
belarús se convirtió en la vía de escape
de muchos migrantes especialmente de
irak siria y afganistán según datos del
gobierno de polonia más de 12.000
personas han intentado cruzar desde
belarús desde principios de octubre
además en la frontera de polonia con
alemania fueron detenidos 209 emigrantes
en agosto
1.164 en septiembre y cerca de 2000 en
octubre